für menschen die nach deutschland ziehen
sind deutsche supermärkte immer wieder
ein interessantes diskussionsthema so
auch für roger lutzi laura und ihr
beschäftigt euch sogar beruflich mit dem
thema wo arbeitet ihr und was macht ihr
die arbeit sind bei der soko zu einer
englischen liga publikation über
deutsche nachrichten und kultur und wir
schreiben im moment einen artikel zum
thema supermärkte
das ist spannend und gemeinsam werden
wir jetzt mal ein paar leute auf der
strasse befragen und euch dinge erzählen
die ihr wissen solltet wenn ihr in den
deutschen supermarkt geht los geht's
[Musik]
in deutschland gibt es ja verschiedene
arten von supermärkten könnten sie
erklären welche art muss oder was ist zb
unterschied zwischen aldi und rewe
welche arten von supermärkten gibt es
okay es gibt einmal den discounter dazu
würde ich aldi und lidl neun kategorien
und dann gibt's denn rewe das für mich
ein normaler supermarkt werde ich kann
sich unterscheiden letztendlich im
detail was heißt normal oder was gibt es
bei aldi nicht was das passive gibt oder
umgekehrt naja die discounter angebote
in großer menge würde ich sagen gibt es
bei lidl und aldi
in deutschland gibt es verschiedene
arten von supermärkten es gibt sehr
große supermärkte fast wie in den usa
und auch kleinere supermärkte der
standard supermarkt ist aber so etwas ja
was nicht so groß ist vielleicht so ein
typischer rewe oder ein typischer edeka
wäre das was die deutschen als standard
supermarkt wahrnehmen und die
verschiedenen märkte unterscheiden sich
auch im sortiment
es gibt supermärkte die sehr eine sehr
große auswahl haben es gibt ja
supermärkte die eine besonders
nachhaltige auswahl haben und es gibt
sogenannte discounter sowie aldi und
lidl
die haben eine kleine auswahl aber sind
dafür sehr billig und vergleicht kennt
ihr die auch denn sowohl aldi als auch
lidl kommen aus deutschland sind aber in
die ganze welt expandiert
und was gibt es in einem biomarkt
bioprodukte warum gehen sie lieber in
den bio supermarkt das ist ein kleiner
und der ist gemütlich und vor allen
dingen weil es doch schmeckt sie müssen
mal bananen kaufen
es geht bei aldi oder präsenz oder dem
graben drehen oder seeed oder milch und
dass generell hoch also auch brot wein
kommen sie zufällig gerade aus dem
supermarkt nein ich habe den extra
gemieden weil ich einen kleinen laden
haben wollte und habe lieber mir klar
gemacht hier seitlich mindestens 50 cent
mehr
und hier weiß ich jetzt nicht so aber
das hat mir mehr spaß gemacht als im
supermarkt zu sein ich wollte da nicht
rein
warum wollten sie nicht in den
supermarkt ja weil einfach dieses
getümmel und dieses viele zeigt was und
diese viele zeitigte auch verschwendet
auf jeden fall länger als in diesem
kleinen laden uns hätte ich euch ja auch
nicht getroffen viele menschen die neu
in deutschland sind empfinden deutsche
supermärkte als stressig zwar kann man
in deutschland auch ganz normal und ganz
in ruhe einkaufen wie in anderen denn
dann auch aber spätestens wenn es zur
kasse geht kommt in deutschland ein
bisschen stress rein
die eine sache sind die neuen kassen
sobald eine neue kasse eröffnet wird ist
es in deutschland nicht so dass man die
menschen vor lässt die schon lange
gewartet haben sondern alle fangen an zu
rennen und der der als erstes da ist
kommt zuerst dran
die zweite sache ist dass man in
deutschland seine waren selbst einpacken
muss
es gibt also niemanden der die sachen
für dich einpackt und dadurch entsteht
für manche leute so im stress gefühl ich
muss schnell meine sachen einpacken
während sie gescannt werden dann schnell
bezahlen denn dann kommt schon die
nächste personen nach hier
[Musik]
und wie ist das in euren ländern muss
man da auch alles ganz schnell einpacken
eigentlich nicht in den usa weil
normalerweise ist eine person am ende
der schlange und dieser person kann
alles schon einpacken
dann geht alles ein bisschen langsamer
weil man wie vorhergesagt so viel schmal
tag macht also man rätselt auch ein
quatsch zwischendurch und in indien in
indien auch haben wir mehr menschen
wir könnten packen für uns es gibt
menschen die für euch die eingriffe
einpacken ja genau so wie erwartet
wie findest du das mit öffnung sein
willst du damit zufrieden in deutschland
oder würdest du lieber immer geöffnet
haben so wie in anderen ländern
also ich kann verstehen ich habe das am
wochenende deswegen kann ich verstehen
dass man gerne wochenend offen hat ich
kann aber auch verstehen dass leute die
am wochenende freuen
in deutschland haben die geschäfte nicht
überall gleich lang geöffnet in größeren
städten haben die geschäfte meistens bis
zehn oder auch bis mitternacht geöffnet
aber sobald man in eine kleine stadt
oder ein dorf kommt kann es sein dass
ein geschäft schon um 18 uhr oder 19 uhr
oder 20 uhr schließt was besonders ist
in deutschland ist der sonntag der
sonntag ist den deutschen wirklich
heilig es ist ein familientag und alle
geschäfte sind sonntags geschlossen
wenn ihr aus einem land kommt wo er
sonntags immer ein kaufen könnt dann
müssen wir das unbedingt wissen denn
sonst steht ihr sonntags dort in
deutschland und könnte gar nichts zu
essen finden können sie irgendwas nennen
was typisch deutsch
in einem supermarkt ist ja das peinliche
finde ich ist doch dass supermärkte sind
der ganzen welt gleich aus das heißt
wenn ich in polen in einem supermarkt
bin ist es schon echt schwer weil es
kenne ich ja alles wenn ich vor 20
jahren in polen im supermarkt gewesen
dann dann hatte ich wirklich noch ein
erlebnis
dann sage ich sage ich produkte die ich
nicht kannte oder vor etwas mehr 20
jahren in den haushaltswaren
geschäftslebens supergeil in italien was
zu sagen es für klamotten siehst kannst
du doch gar nicht in deutschland
also was ist typisch so weiß ich ja
nicht weil ich da ständig bin ja wie
empfinden sie das personal also
kassiererinnen kassierer sind die
freundlich in deutschland oder gibt es
auch unterschiede
ich muss selber offen sein wenn ich
selber hingehen und sagen tag oder bin
freundlich dann krieg ich auch oftmals
eine freundlichkeit zurück
aber nicht immer und ich habe eine
kulturelle frage als jemand der aus der
schweiz kommt wahrscheinlich leute in
berlin freut ich war jemand aus berlin
von ihnen ist das freundlich so was hat
die kulturelle unterschiede wahrnehmen
insofern kann man das nicht so wird wo
gibt's denn deutschland die nettesten
supermärkte nettesten menschen im
service in berlin
dies ist aber echt schwierig ich glaube
nicht unbedingt jetzt in berlin die
vierte besonderheit über die wir heute
sprechen ist die freundlichkeit in
deutschen supermärkten deutschen sind
sehr speziell wenn es darum geht mit
fremden zu reden sie mögen small talk
nicht besonders und auch im service
zeigt sich dass die leute sind nicht
übermäßig freundlich
je nachdem wo man in deutschland ist
kann das stark variieren aber ihr sollt
auf jeden fall nicht geschockt sein wenn
ihr an der kasse steht und weder andere
kunden noch der kassierer mit euch redet
oder sogar vielleicht ein bisschen
unfreundliche antwort gibt auf eure
fragen wenn ihr zum beispiel aus den usa
kommt wird euch das wahrscheinlich sehr
schockieren dann ist es sehr anders dort
aber in deutschland ist das tatsächlich
völlig normal dass man kaum redet und
noch eine frage waren sich immer im
ausland
in anderen supermärkten sind ihnen
unterschiede aufgefallen
die haben mir ist aufgefallen dass es
zum beispiel in spanischen supermärken
die plastiktüten leider noch kostenfrei
dazu gibt ja und die ware da auch
eingepackt wird was ich tat einen coach
findet und hier man ja glücklicherweise
mittlerweile schon dafür bezahlen muss
ja und warum finden sie das gut weil
viele menschen kommen nach deutschland
denken wieso wird das turnier nicht
eingepackt wieso muss ich denn für eine
tüte zahlen na ja es liegt ja auch
verhandeln weil es nachhaltiger ist und
weil es nicht so wegwerf gesellschaft
beiträgt und wir somit halte ja kein
naja oder das minimieren können unser
plastikmüll problem
jetzt freuen wir uns auf eure meinung
und eure erfahrungen welche erfahrungen
habt ihr in deutschen supermärkten
gemacht schreibt es uns mal in die
kommentare
und ihr könnt diese woche noch mehr
lesen denn unsere vier gäste von local
werden auch einen artikel dazu
veröffentlichen
wo finden sie den ihr konntet den
artikel auf die local germany finden
oder blog.de genau und den artikel
verlinken wir uns auch hier unten in der
infobox könnt ihr mal drauf klicken und
dann findet ihr noch mehr interessante
hintergründe zu ihren meinungen zu
unseren erfahrungen und ihr könnt
natürlich auch wie immer ein fan von
easy german werden das geht wenn ihr
hier darauf geht dann bekommt er
vokabeln listen ein transkript und
interaktive übungen zu diesem video und
zu allen anderen videos bei easyjet und
hier könnt ihr sie german abonnieren
tschüss und bis zum nächsten woche danke
dass ihr dabei war